[Música]
[Aplausos]
mola hola qué tal cómo estáis yo
vengo a hablaros si bien el anterior
ponente estuvo hablando de los 10
últimos años de su vida yo voy a hablar
de los 15 primeros de la mía
porque sé distinto no es más voy a
hablar de eso de ser distintos del valor
de la diferencia ósea y el valor de la
diferencia estamos en un mundo en el que
se persigue muchísimo ser diferente ser
distinto a los demás de hecho si eres
distinto enseguida te quieren etiquetar
o sea si tienes barba enseguida te pone
y te dicen pues eres era hipster
si tienes el pelo largo pues será hippie
o heavy
si llevas el pelo así como cortado
malamente y tal como si no le pagas es
al peluquero será futbolista
hay que ver qué mal se corta en el pelo
los judíos parece que no tienen dinero
para cortarse de igual no
si intentas etiquetar y a la vez
está tan penalizado el ser
el ser distinto y a la vez te piden que
seas genial como narices puede ser
genial si eres igual al resto
o sea es imposible entonces yo vengo a
proclamar el valor de la diferencia
yo salta a la vista soy distinto a todos
vosotros
se nota no
yo soy guapo
y esa distinción
fue toda la vida toda la vida
y voy a hablaros un poco de la vida
porque a mí lo que me interesa a ver yo
tengo un dicho que es
que evolucionado un poco como las
televisiones cuando estaba de joven
activo jugando a baloncesto estaba
cuadrado y ahora digamos que estoy más
panorámico nunca
y esperar unos años que veréis como
empiezo a sentir dimensional pero al
margen de eso
lo que vengo a hablar es de ese cambio
de cuando estaba al cuadrado hasta ahora
o de cuando empecé estar cuadrado hasta
ahora
y todo empezó
pues eso yo fui un niño muy querido por
mis padres pero esto fue grande y es eso
de mucha gente viene y me pregunta y tú
cuando empezaste a ser grande toda
mi vida o sea esto no es que te
despiertas una noche te acuestas te
acuestas como el anterior ponente así
con una talla tipo pokemon
[Aplausos]
o el odio a que parecía que estaba lejos
que no era bajito el tema obviamente
ahora que no está no
no no es que te acuestas como él y te
levantas con 213 no o sea yo fui grande
toda mi vida sea imaginaros como fue lo
mío
6 kilos y medio
13 horas de parto mi madre
sabéis por qué llevo pulseritas de estas
es un tema desde la infancia me viene
porque en el nido a mí no me ponían
pulserita decían ese 6 veis que todos
los niños
qué muy triste lo mío no solo no me
tiene en cuenta o sea yo vengo aquí a
contar mis tristezas todos los niños yo
a una pulserita con su nombre tal es más
el moisés se llama moisés no eso que le
hacen a los niños eso donde colocan los
niños en el nido el de matrimonio
ya se salió así los brazos y la tierra
que pasó o sea era eso y a partir de ahí
pues fue la vida en el colegio en todo
fuera yo no sabía que era distinto
porque verdaderamente un niño nos hay
pero no hay nada peor que ser distinto
en un colegio como te lo hacen pagar
o sea no era fácil en nosotros uno de
viajar con los grandes que eras tal no
se pueden apagar días a todos' y serías
el matón de la clase una
o sea me las llevaba de todos los
colores porque porque si me peleaba de
mi cama con los de mi tamaño
con eso de que eran de que eran mayores
me cerraban si me peleaba con los de mi
edad como eso de que era mucho más
pequeño me cerraban los padres con lo
cual me las llevaba de todos los colores
y después en el colegio no era fácil o
sea imaginaros clase de parvulario no
una clase de parvulario una silla
como esta pero más pequeñita bueno
podríamos decir que como yo también era
más pequeño pues más o menos entonces yo
me tenía que meter en una silla así que
para meterme no te cambia la pierna
entonces estaba así este era la clase de
calcular o sea en un sitio donde no
cabía es una claustrofobia horrible eso
está
entonces que hacía me ponían una silla
de mayor y entonces yo estaba sentado en
una silla de mayor
y cada vez que hablaba me castigaban en
que me castigaban a la silla de los
pequeños ahí estaba yo constreñido pero
no cuestión de además de lo que de lo
que hiciese yo sino también era cuestión
de lo que hacían el resto no porque
detrás de mí claro yo era como una
pantalla para la profesora detrás de mí
no se veía nada o sea haber detrás de mí
hacía un examen y sacaban hasta les pasa
a los judíos o sea yo le decía archivar
o salgo hockey tampoco esas va a haber
si podéis hacer hasta mi examen me
lo pone nana horrible todos los que
hablaban todos los amparos se sentaban
detrás de mí yo no porque yo era muy
buen niño allí en coruña y estaba y
además
en un colegio
en el colegio y
y no sabía yo sabía que de distinto a
los demás pero no le encontraba utilidad
a mi vida o sea es más para mí mi vida
era una solemne guardada yo estaba en
cuarto de bachiller y tenía el la
gimnasia que todos nos hacía educación
física era gimnasia de primero sin
aprobar y si tenía sede primero tenía el
segundo y tenía la de tercero y la de 4º
y por qué porque en primero me hacían
saltar
el examen de final del curso era saltar
el potro interior
y sabemos lo que es el potro no cuatro
palos un cacharro así forrado de cuero
que con una altura más o menos así que
saltar lo era lo de menos porque yo
podía hacer así daba igual pero pero
bueno no pero tenía que apoyar las manos
y entre las manos y el cacharro infame
tenía que meter
el cuerpo las piernas y el cincuenta y
tantos de pie la física no da para tanto
ósea
no sé cómo hacía yo me encanta el viento
dado aquí horrible horrible o sea hasta
que un día no sé cómo hice lo salté y me
dijeron bien te vas examinar de segundo
que era segundo
el clinton de hacer la voltereta en el
clinton no me jodas el cacharro así que
eran cajones que se ponían uno encima de
otro cada vez más pequeños
entonces arriba era una colchoneta y así
estrecha y yo tenía yo que tengo culo
para tres espaldas como podía darle la
voltereta imposible o sea y es que a
todos le hacía mo dijo hoy salta y toca
arriba pues yo sería fácil por eso no lo
pedía no lo que podían hacer cosas era
hacer cosas imposibles y yo me
encontraba como fuera de situación como
diciendo dios mío esto va a ser toda mi
vida hasta que de repente
llega a
a clase un chaval alto también no tanto
como yo yo soy gallego sé de la coruña
no sé si os lo he dicho no yo soy
gallego de la coruña si algo nos
caracteriza los gallegos hay por ahí
algún gallego más por lo que es el 112
si algo nos caracteriza los gallegos es
que haber capacidad de decisión
inmediata como que no tenemos
o sea esto de decir esto va así así
porque no entonces llega este chaval y
me dice oye pero tú eres alto yo decía
algo de vito avispado que no
porque no juegas a baloncesto y digo y
para qué voy a jugar a baloncesto dice
hambre tos porque yo creo que te vendría
bien y adif o al baloncesto también de
hoy ahí cómo se hace eso y dice pues
bien es entrenar a vale y tal y entonces
nos tiramos haciéndonos preguntas uno a
otro como 45 minutos una hora y tal y al
final decido que voy a entrenar al
baloncesto
y ahí
se abre un mundo nuevo para mí
porque ahí me di cuenta de que era mi
razón de ser yo había nacido no para
jugar a baloncesto sino pero pero era
una de las posibilidades que se me abría
y ahí empezó un camino mira todos
tenemos referentes
en todos los referentes que
a los cuales acudimos yo como era pívot
el referente miedo al base y el base era
juan corvalán
y juan corvalán tiene un dicho más o
menos espera lo voy a leer porque el tío
es muy poco rebuscado no vais a perdonar
nos pasamos la vida buscando un hueco en
ella
el éxito está en que nunca nos olvidemos
de dónde venimos esto dice cuan corro
juan corvalán
o sea hace falta ser cursi para decir
esta frase o sea nunca si es de nadie
que mida menos de dos metros o sea los
enanos son así muy raros o sea como lo
diría un pívot un tío como es debido la
vida es un camino donde aprendemos
continuamente fernando romay
semifinalista de mira quién baila
pues eso la vida es camino los éxitos a
mí estaba leyendo y además es que me da
hasta puro que lean a pesar de que digan
que fue la olimpiada del 64 por dijo el
pero
me
me da igual cuando fuese los éxitos yo
no sé ni qué liga se gana o que hombre
de medallas olímpicas solo tuve una pues
si me acuerdo o no
pero si me dices campeonatos liga hasta
no sé que no tengo ni idea porque por
los éxitos están todos en una vitrina y
al cabo del tiempo esos éxitos lejos de
son de estar brillantes y ser no
empiezan las medallas a negrura de
estas y tienes que estar limpiando todo
el día
y tu mujer te dice son tus medallas
límpialo tú y te ves el fin de semana
dale que te pego allí con el
algodoncillo ese bañado para que no se
vaya el brillo y tal y además es un
engorro y están por acá si ya no sabes
ni dónde está ni la mitad de ellas pero
en cambio lo que te queda para siempre
son las vivencias
y eso es lo malo la gente que lejos de
hacer camino lo que que lo que quiere es
buscar el éxito y esa gente es la que
sale en los telediarios siempre porque
el éxito sin camino lo que te lleves a
conseguirlo de formas poco ortodoxas
incluso ilegales y lo que tenemos que
hacer es buscar el camino siempre el
camino tenemos mucho camino acabamos de
ver un ejemplo de una persona que
empezaba caminos distintos siempre con
una cosa que basada en la ilusión y
sobre todo romper el paradigma
o sea eso de que el paradigma que es una
verdad inexorable ante una situación
pues hay que romperlo continuamente cómo
es posible que aquel chaval que con 13
años tenía sin aprobar la gimnasia de
cuatro cursos para atrás cuatro años más
tarde
estuviese ganando una medalla con la
selección española de baloncesto de
junior
imposible porque porque no se podía dar
si no tenías aprobado la gimnasia de
primero como podías hacerlo
pero no pero sí porque simplemente
cuando llegué al baloncesto me dijeron
tú eres válido para esto y esto es lo
que lo que vas a hacer y lo que vas a y
para para esto te necesitamos trabaja y
consigue lo y me lo creí y trabajé y
trabajé muy duro y todo fue ya bueno a
todo esto me volvemos otra vez a lo de
antes a lo del que me coge
me empiezo a jugar a baloncesto en mi
coruña natal y en esto como a los 6
meses al año de estar entrenando yo no
había jugado ni un partido no y entonces
me cogen y recibe una llamada de
teléfono una llamada de teléfono y me
dice ahora muy buenas soy tomás gonzález
de las cuevas fuentes con dos y
apellido que vas
y dice soy entrenador de los juveniles
del real madrid queremos que vengas a
aprobar por nosotros para ver si te
fichan vivo y para qué
desde para jugar a baloncesto y porque
dice oye chaval estamos en el año 73
esto es conferencia sale por un pico no
me hagas preguntas chorras dime si
vienes o no y entonces dije póngale
pongo el voy voy y me fui a probar por
el real madrid me prueba por realmadrid
fue lo más sui generis de todas las
pruebas que se hicieron el real madrid
yo empiezo lejos de ser un
erudito avanzado como el anterior
ponente que todo lo que hacía lo hacía
bien yo llego y me voy a probar con los
campeones de españa gente que había
están en selección los mejores que
querían jugar en el real madrid de
juveniles
a todo esto hay alguien del barça por
aquí que levanten la mano
vale vale lo lleváis claro el tema
entonces voy a probar claro de la gente
madrid- el resto
entonces
el que tenemos muy buen rollo pero muy
mal ambiente
y entonces
estaba allí y dice ponte a jugar con
ellos
entonces me pongo a jugar con ellos y a
los 3 minutos me dicen no nos sale fuera
dice que lo hecho bien no dice no lo has
hecho fatal tío vete a la canasta del
fondo y tira allí a ver está yo me pongo
a tirar y a los cinco minutos me dice ya
afuera dice que el 8 viene y dice no no
no lo has hecho fatal te dice vete con
el preparador físico del preparador
físico empezó hacer una serie de
ejercicios y la cuestión acabó más o
menos así en una línea del campo tenía
que ir andando con los ojos cerrados
si no se separa mucho no está muy para
allá y podemos hacer algo con él claro
calzo un 50 y tantos llegó los pies un
poco para adentro si tenía que separarme
me tendría que salir casi de la isla
para no pisar la línea o sea entonces yo
fui andando así y tal por una línea pim
pam pum pum y fui pisando la todo el
rato y dice hombre pues yo creo que que
si puede valer podemos hacer algo con él
y entonces veo que sube tomás gonzález a
hablar con los entrenadores con lolo
sainz con fernando y yo veía que tomás
gonzález hacía gestos del tenor d
así tal
y los otros solo hacían un gesto
y yo muy espabilado no era pero lo iba
pillando
y el otro
y esto es diciendo
que me voy a casa y en esto baja tomas y
me dice
te vas a quedar por un solo motivo
1756 y cuanto tengo
o sea que ya acabó ya vale pues ya lo
acabo ya te vas a quedar con un motivo
por un motivo porque creo en ti
la frase que cambió mi
creo en ti y desde entonces pienso
que todos debemos buscar a alguien que
cree en nosotros
y una vez que tienes cierto empaque
cierta relevancia o ciertos años lo que
tienes es buscar gente en qué creer
tenemos que creer muchísimo más en la
gente que tenemos a nuestro lado así que
simplemente
que queden dos cosas unos romper el
paradigma que vuestros sueños no están
coartados por que la gente diga que no
podéis realizarlos y segundo el camino
es lo más importante los éxitos ya
vendrán dados cuanto más caminos hagáis
más posibilidades de éxito tenéis y
tercero
y muy importante creer creer y creer
y tener quien crea en vosotros
y 4to y último
buscar vuestra diferencia si eres igual
al resto un mal rollo nunca podrá ser
genial antes tuvimos un ponente que es
genial porque es distinto al resto ahora
tenéis uno que simplemente es guapo
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
y